love island for geopolitics the leaders
of the world's richest nations have
arrived the first face-to-face summit
since the pandemic began are you
supposed to be looking at as if you're
enjoying yes
[Music]
it is vital
that we don't repeat the mistake of the
last green crisis last great economic
recession in 2008 we don't repeat the
mistake of 2008.
the crowd are attacking a branch of the
rbs band
[Applause]
our society is still scarred
by too much unfairness and inequality
the fat cats they rob all money
[Music]
i still ask myself what else you know
could have been done in those in those
circumstances the sense of anger and
alienation that wasn't appearing in any
of this consensus was there on the
streets what i wanted to do was use the
political honeymoon that you get after
an election to do the hard stuff george
osborne needs to stop drinking the
kool-aid he got it wrong
the government just poured enormous
quantities of money into the system
those of us in private equity got
incredibly wealthy in one day basically
i've made as much money as my dad made
in his whole career and it just was
owners of assets have all made out like
bandits
those at the top have never done better
but average wages have barely butched
this was us saying actually didn't look
after us you neglected us you treated us
badly and here we are the big winners of
the last 10 to 12 years um have been
those at the top it's a very simple
story the fact that we've got nurses
going to food banks multinationals we've
bought against big politics
[Applause]
people felt
you know we'd been told that we should
accept the discipline of a market
economy
and it wasn't being applied to the elite
there's one rule for the rest of us but
a different rule for the elite
we had what is called the traders off
site which is where all the traders in
the world get together have a bit of a
jolly up and talk about like what we're
going to do that year um and
that year early 2011 it was held in a
country manner and i think hertfordshire
when we went in
i couldn't believe it they gave us um
and they gave us these hats these hats
here
stand on the front go big or go home
and the the idea behind this is
if you're willing to take a bet in
one million dollars take it in 10
million dollars if you if you back
yourself in one million dollars do it
intent telling us all right take way
more risk and um
i couldn't believe it right okay because
it's only two years after we the bank
basically brought the world economy to
its knees by taking too much risk
their incentivizers to take a load of
risk and they know if it doesn't work
out they're already millionaires they're
not going to lose out you know they
might get a bailout anyway so they just
want us to take a ton of risk and oh
yeah i've never claimed to be like a
great sort of
moral philosopher but this is it's
taking the piss to be honest isn't it
really i mean i took massive amounts of
risk as a very young trader and because
i was making money nobody really
questioned it um
risks
risk management got a little bit tighter
as i got as i got a bit older so the
incentivization on traders is not to
like take massive bets and win traders
now have massive salaries and not big
bonuses
so
[Music]
i wanted to understand why
this recovery wasn't happening
and i started to think well
these rich people are not going to boost
the economy because they get the money
or they're doing is buying houses buying
stocks and chairs
so what's probably going to happen is
house price is going to go up stock
price is going to go up the economy's
not going to recover and i started to
bet very heavily
that actually there will never be a
recovery on the back of this bet that
there will never be an economic recovery
i became citibank's
globally most profitable trader in
foreign exchange and short-term interest
rates
[Music]
house prices have risen by an average of
8.4 percent over 2013
the rich are obviously winning
poor people obviously losing but there's
this real problem i think where people
in the middle are seeing their house
prices going up
they think they're winning
but it's gonna cause their kids and
their grandkids to not have homes
to live
[Music]
my job was to look at the economy and
take the temperature is it good is it
bad you know i come from a poor
background my friends come from poor
backgrounds my family comes from a poor
background i can see all the new people
are being affected
but now i'm a millionaire right and i'm
sitting down and i'm looking at the
economy and
i'm saying what i think is going to
happen i think it's going to be a
disaster i think it's going to be
rubbish for years for decades
and i could bet on that again and i
could make another million quid again
but then after the money hit the bank it
just didn't feel right basically anymore
i know it has been hard for families
since the crash
it's not a case of not understanding
these difficulties
it's a case of being honest about why
things are difficult so here's another
hard truth welfare cannot be protected
from further substantial cuts i thought
all right the problems inequality
we're not going to fix it i started to
feel like
i need to tell someone like if you know
a disaster is going to happen you need
to say something right you know what i
mean like if you know your neighbor's
house is going to burn down you don't
bet on it you tell them right and then
my boss called me in for like half in a
meeting i hadn't really planned it and i
just said
i don't think i can do this anymore i
think i think i need to quit
[Music]
covid worst economic crisis since the
great depression basically
stocks gone up gone up the government
just poured enormous quantities of money
into the system those of us in private
equity got incredibly wealthy you do now
have uh billionaires launching rockets
into space
when you're working 70 hours 80 hours
even 90 hours a week just to make
nothing that can't be right
the big winners of the last 10 to 12
years um have been those at the top it's
a very simple story it's a story of
inequality the fact that we've got
nurses going to food banks the type of
politicians we've had this far have
created this mess people felt
you know we'd been told that we should
accept the discipline of a market
economy
and it wasn't being applied to the elite
there's one rule for the rest of us but
a different rule for the elite
[Music]
the massive thing we understand is that
simply printing money is not anywhere
close to as effective as
economists thought it was going to be
it's a very very weak tool
after a paid leave package passed today
this would be the biggest wave of money
unlocked to combat the coronavirus the
size and the urgency of this is
evocative of the bank rescue package
from the financial crisis
today i can announce it for the first
time in our history the government is
going to step in and help to pay
people's wages
breaking news the federal reserve is
signaling moments ago it will take major
new action to prop up the economy look
at that
right off the bat the dow jones up six
percent we've gone straight up at this
moment the dow industrials are up close
to twelve 1200 points
the bank of england is pumping an
additional hundred billion pounds into
the financial system markets riding a
wave of euphoria
we have used economic policy very
actively and very substantially and
that's i mean has to be the right thing
to do in the current circumstances it
keeps liquidity in the economy available
for other uses because it supports
businesses and it supports households
kobe
worst economic crisis since the great
depression basically
stocks gone up gone up what it has
created is a bizarre situation where the
consequence of economic collapse and the
consequence of economic crisis
is repeatedly a massive increase in
stock and asset prices and who owns
stocks and who owns assets well
mainly it's wealthy people
thai economy has come to a stand still
government has been mismanaging the
economy miss rule really been passed
[Music]
calculations by oxfam suggest the
combined wealth of 10 of the world's
richest men has increased during the
coronavirus pandemic by 400 billion
pounds
the rich are getting richer everyone
else is getting poorer if it continues
we're gonna wind up with an even more
volatile society in which everybody
hates each other
they're taxing me on unemployment
they're taxing me at every corner i get
but you have a man that's a billionaire
and all of them are being this and
they're not being taxed tell me where
the right and wrong is in that those in
poverty were nearly four times more
likely to die from covid than more
affluent groups says the pandemic has
widened the gap between rich and poor in
the uk
for an illustrated look into the wealth
gap and how it affects us all head over
to bbc dot co dot uk forward slash
decade the rich one and follow the links
to the open university
[Music]
how are you feeling here
um
it's
i don't know how i feel it might be
emotional
it's a bit emotional
yeah all congratulations man yeah good
good kid
i'll stop now